Profiles in holography is brought to you through the generous support of the International Holography Fund.
For more information, visit their website at holographyfund.org.
This is Frank Defratis, and I would like to welcome you to Holo Talks Profiles in Holography.
This series of internet broadcasts focuses specifically on art holography and the artists who create the work.
My guest for this installment is Australian artist Amy Rush.
I hope you enjoy our informal chat and that you return for all of the upcoming broadcasts in the series.
And now here's Amy Rush.
May I speak to Amy Rush, please?
Yes, it's me.
Oh hello.
Hello.
I called a little earlier, a few minutes ago, and then I got Anna Maria's other number, and she's out in San Francisco.
Yeah, yeah, it's true.
But she told me to just keep trying and somebody will pick up, and that's true.
Someone did.
Oh, that's great.
I was just waiting, um I was waiting at a sushi restaurant for a takeaway sushi.
Oh.
And they were taking a really long time and I was like, oh no.
I'm gonna move Frank.
How is the time right now?
Is it okay for you or are you eating lunch?
It's good, it's perfect.
I don't want to come in between your you and Sushi.
No.
It's okay.
Um I mean I've had the big breakfast already and the sushi is like cold sushi anyway.
Do you think it doesn't it doesn't matter at all?
I can I can wait for my sushi.
It can be my reward after I speak with you.
Okay, good.
How are things going with your installation?
Um well they're going okay.
I've had a few um difficulties like with the lights because I bought all the lights from Australia.
Okay.
And I had to change the voltage of them.
Oh, yes.
Oh, jeez.
Yeah, and also I had this other problem where I um I wasn't allowed to bring my holograms in hand luggage.
Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, because they were too big.
Oh, okay.
So some of them actually broke, which was really Oh, Amy.
I know.
It was really sad, but but then something good happened out of the whole thing because um I I I spoke to the people in Germany where the the they were made, the stereograms and they um have offered to reprint some of them for me.
Oh, that's wonderful.
Yeah, so it kind of worked out anyway and I'm I'm getting new ones printed too, so it's it's even more exciting for me now.
That's good.
Now the the holograms that w broke were they on glass plates or are they film and just the plexiglass or something cracked?
No, no, they're they're on glass plates.
Oh and um no no no, sorry, it's it's film laminated onto glass.
Oh, I see.
I see.
But um it's it's really hard to get it off.
Like I've done some tests and the the film kind of just evaporates.
But um I've decided never ever to laminate my my um my film ever again onto glass.
Yeah, it's it's a shame that it had to take something like this though to make you make that decision.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, I think it's kind of hard to carry and it's kind of um really fragile and you know, if you just have them on on a film and you roll them up or if you put them you know you can show them without the glass I think.
I'm not gonna do it anymore with glass.
Yeah.
I work on glass plates.
Oh yeah so you know you know that they break, you know, it's horrible.
So between holograms breaking and being stolen I don't have uh a lot of them are gone now.
Have you had some of yours stolen?
Oh yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
What happened?
I had a I had one stolen from an actual museum one time.
I don't know how they ever got out the door with one of those you should take that as a big compliment.
Well I did at the time, but now that years have gone by I'd rather have the hologram back.
I wonder where it is I I often wonder where it is.
Oh my goodness.
So why don't you let the listeners know you're on what's called a world tour.
That sounds pretty exciting.
Yeah.
Did you have T shirts made up with all the uh cities that you're visiting or tell us about the world tour.
Okay, well um it kind of started in Australia last month.
I just finished my thesis so it's kind of like a very big um uh reward as you might say.
And so in this exhibition um we we started in uh Sydney and I had an exhibition at um the College of Fine Arts um exhibition space.
Okay.
And that was really it was really wonderful because I never had ever exhibited my holograms in Sydney, Australia before.
And that's where I um that's where I'm born and where I live and and stuff like this.
So it was really exciting to show all my friends and my family all the different work that I've been doing over these years and it was really amazing also because no I mean, in in Sydney, Australia there's there'sn't hardly ever any hologram exhibitions.
Oh, isn't that a shame?
It is but um it was kind of interesting because people just came in and if you didn't show them the work, like to l how to look at the work and explain to them, you know, that you have to look stand in front and move your body and your eyes, they would just walk in and walk straight out again without seeing it.
Like they would just poke their head in.
So I had to have my boyfriend come in, I mean, standing in there the whole time and, you know, explaining to the people and they were just totally overwhelmed, you know, they were like, What I what is this?
Oh wow, how I see it now.
I see it now.
Come over here, look at this.
I see it, look and it was so exciting, you know, to have these people experience the medium of hologram through my own work.
Yes, yeah.
Yeah, so I I was really p pleased and you know, there was a lot of students that got to st see it as well and they were all asking, like, where can we do this?
How can we do this?
You know, and you know, just really excited and enthusiastic about everything.
So it was it was good.
Okay, so that's where the the tour began.
Mm-hmm.
And then um like about one day after we took the the exhibition down, we we came straight to New York to the Centre for Holographic Arts where where I made some holograms in the past.
Yeah, and you were uh part of the artists in residency program as an or an intern or something there?
Oh yeah, well I was an intern like right at the beginning of my interest in holography in two thousand and three.
Mm-hmm.
So I stayed here for about um six months and made my first series of work.
And yeah, so it's amazing to be back here because um you know like I haven't been here for maybe um four years and to see everybody that that was here and that helped me at the beginning and the people that like didn't really know what I was doing since I came here and I get to show them all the new stuff and so that's really nice and yeah I'm just setting it up, like setting up the show and it's gonna open on the eighth of um the eighth of December.
Yeah, December exactly And let me let the listeners know because you know th these shows get archived.
Uh-huh.
So that anyone can listen to people are still listening to shows that were done ten years ago.
So let me let the listeners know that we're talking about December eighth two thousand and seven.
Because if someone's listening ten years from now it's gonna be two thousand and seventeen.
Oh wow You know so it's two thousand and seven.
Well hello out there in the future So you move from and you know you left Australia which is summertime to come up to New York City which is going into the dead of winter.
I know I know and and to make things more extreme we're actually going to Iceland in January.
What's with holography in Iceland?
Well, I don't know if there's much there's much happening in holography in Iceland, but um I believe that Iceland would be the most ideal country to display holograms because it's dark all the time.
Mm-hmm.
And they're interested in um supernatural things like ghosts and they have a lot of folklores and um, you know, they have the northern lights as well, so they kind of have this, you know, interest in life I guess too.
And yeah, so I think I think that they might be my most um excited audience.
That's what I'm expecting.
Wow.
Yeah.
And how do you put did you put this tour together yourself?
Yeah, yeah, I did.
I kind of applied for some um residencies and some um asked some people that I knew that have made um that hosted holographic exhibitions before.
Okay.
Yeah, so I kind of just like m asked some people and kind of, you know, um applied for some things and then it kind of fitted together somehow.
Let's uh put a plug in for Jonathan Ross as well, because then you'll be heading over to England I imagine, right?
Yeah, we're going there and in in February and I think our show will open like maybe on the fifth of February in yeah, in um in London.
Mm-hmm.
I never went to London before.
No kidding.
No.
I've never been to London either.
Really?
Yeah.
Why don't you tell the listeners about the types of holograms that you've created as far as uh the format of holography that you prefer to work in.
Okay.
Um well the the thing that I really love and the thing that um I I've focused all my holograms in is the the transmission white light hologram, the rainbow hologram.
And so I first started making analog analogue holograms.
Rainbow holograms from um Pulse Master copies.
I mean so Pulse Masters.
And then I um made copies of them on the on the table and yeah, I just made some of them were um two uh do you say two frames or two expo two exposures.
Okay, yeah, double exposure.
D double exposures.
And then um yeah, so I did that and I was really happy with the result of having 'cause it had a lot of depth in it and it was also um able to to capture real moments of of time.
And what happens with that?
When you walk past it, one image sort of fades into another.
Yeah, yeah.
So the first one I made was like this um this kind of image of myself as a as a rainbow fairy princess like winking winking.
So I my it's like a double exposure one, you know, and when you go in front of it I I wink at you.
It kind of inspired from the eighties porn holograms that they were making.
Oh.
I haven't seen any of those.
I know.
There's a really cute kind of um I guess style or something that they did.
You know, these ones that where the girl you see the girl undresses or something?
Okay.
Kind of yeah, I was kind of I don't have any of those in my collection.
Oh I'm so happy.
And yeah, okay, so then after I started doing the analogue holograms, um I I was invited to the Kaha M, the Ca Academy of Media Arts where they had a stereogram machine.
And they they make eight seconds um stereograms which is so that's eight times twenty five frames.
Okay.
Of mo of um mo uh digital movie or digital still images um that are exposed next to each other and they can create a really nice movement, like a a lot of movement and sometimes you can make the depth if you play with the camera like z zooming in or zooming out or something.
And then after those the stereogram I also made um the dot matrix.
Oh, okay.
Two dot matrix printed ones there they were digital ones as well.
And I really liked the the way that they were just so bright.
You know, if you're looking at them the rainbow was almost reflected onto your onto your face.
Wow.
Yeah.
Yeah, so that th those are the types of ones that I made.
They're all the rainbow rainbow nature.
Do you have any interest in doing reflection holography at all?
Um no not really.
I was just totally interested in the rainbow ones actually, right?
Yeah, well I like I mean I like this idea of making images inside a inside a rainbow.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so that was that was kind of the whole thing with holog holography was that you could make each pixel or each um each piece of the film be every single colour all at once depending on the viewer's position.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that can all be programmed with the dot matrix printer, right?
Yeah, or you can you can choose which pixel is which color.
Yeah.
And yeah, then that that kind of um makes makes all the colours, yeah, when you go up and down and it's just because you're using real colours I mean r R G B like red, green, blue and all the ones in between, it's it's actually really, really bright.
And then that's output onto film, right?
That's not a uh uh is that embossed holography or is that onto film?
Uh no no it's it's onto film.
Okay.
Each each pixel is exposed one by one in a kind of a printer I think.
Who are some of the people you've done a lot of collaborations, right?
Mm-hmm.
Who who are some of the people that you've collaborated with on what projects?
Um well I usually uh c collaborate with whoever is around at the time like I'll I received a lot of help from the technical um aspect like all of my holograms have been collaborations in that in that way because I've always had help from from people who are quite experienced.
In the lab, right?
Yeah, in in the lab.
And um but also like whenever I make a show or an exhibition I have people, you know, like I like I like to work with the people that that are around me or that are inspiring me as well.
Like I made some some show with my with my boyfriend John Arm Sultony and also I made Is he working with holography as well or is it other media?
No he's making he's making ceramics and so what we did was we made a show together where he exhibited his ceramics um and I exhibited my holograms in a kind of an installation together.
Mm-hmm.
And so that was really interesting.
It was really m material and um really immaterial.
Yes.
Yeah, and it was it was a really nice result.
I think um we also have really different subjec subject matter as well, so that was kind of um it was like a boy fantasy versus girl fantasy, like he had all these battleships and demons and stuff, and I had all these fairies and rainbows.
Oh, I see.
So that was kind of um the result of that one and yeah, no, I I do make make a collaboration with whoever is around and I all I mean the exhibition that I have at the moment is a collaboration also with four other artists who are making rainbow holograms.
Okay.
So that's um an artist from another artist from Australia.
Do you wanna give their names?
Yeah, um Martina um Mongrovis.
Oh, okay, yeah.
She's um do you know her?
The name, I've never met her.
Oh, okay.
She she's making holograms in Australia.
She's working at the RMIT in Melbourne and she she gave me a hologram to to show in the exhibition of a boat and um my friend Guillermo Hines is working at the Kahay M Academy of Media Arts and he he made a a a portrait series of me, so I'm using one of those holograms to exhibit.
Okay.
And then also there's a a woman called Paul and Nina Romez and she um made this um beautiful rainbow stereogram of this lor keats from Argentina and then there's also a c a South Korean artist called Pak Ju Stop and he made this kind of um rainbow cube for the exhibition which is like a glass cube with a with a rainbow uh hologram laminate to the back of it so it looks like a a large kind of pixel rainbow or something.
Wow, that's quite a show.
Yeah, so it has um I it wasn't just my work that I included, no, it was it was I wanted to include the works of of my friends also.
Oh it does say Amy Rush and Friends.
Yeah.
Yeah, well I mean, you know, it's it's nice to it's nice to have friends.
Sure.
I had a uh a show with a gentleman that lives here in this area of Pennsylvania and we both put our work in this gallery and he was an artist that would take three dimensional objects and paint them in such a way that they would look flat.
Oh.
And of course I did holography, which is essentially a flat plate which shows a three dimensional object.
So it was like uh flip side of a coin.
You would look at his stuff and his three dimensional objects would go flat and you'd look at my stuff and my two dimensional plate would go to three D.
So it was uh very complimentary.
Yeah, no, it I think it's really nice to to to kind of uh bring it bring it into a wider thing like 'cause you have your own way of working, but then there's so many other people in the w in the world and it creates a a kind of a visual conversation and yeah, I think it's really interesting.
What are some of your future plans?
Do you plan on staying in the field of holography, or is this something that you're touching on and you'll probably move on to some other type of media at some point?
Um, I'm not sure, like I'm really interested in trying to to incorporate holography in in installate in installation, like maybe with music or or sculpture or um musical sculpture or kind of kind of um I would like to collaborate with m musicians.
Okay.
To kind of create holographic performance or something like this.
Like I I really like making these um these kind of static images, you know, that not static 'cause they're moving, but but I really I don't know about just having it in a space, you know, in a gallery kind of where everything is hung one by one.
Like I I'd more like to to work in spa in a space and interact with the space and kind of um create a a more of a whole holistic experience for the the people to to enter.
Okay.
Yeah, like I'm going to Iceland in in next month to make a uh a cave, uh frozen ice cave.
Wow.
With f with holograms that are frozen inside icicles.
Oh my goodness.
And also um speakers that are frozen inside icicles and different um LEDs that are frozen inside icicles and I want to install it inside a a real ice cave.
Wow.
And maybe work with some local musicians to um to perform in there also.
Bjork is from Iceland, right?
Yeah, she is.
Well, there you go.
Yeah, uh I think, you know, the funny thing is she's actually performing in Australia.
Oh while we're gonna be in Iceland But um uh maybe I mean I've actually met her before once on an aeroplane.
No kidding.
I was stuck at in in Spain, um I I lost my I didn't have my ticket to go to New York or they wouldn't let me on the plane 'cause it was a one way one way ticket and it was at the time where they were very um hi hyper security if you you can't enter the country if you don't have a ticket out from there.
Yes.
And so I was actually at the airport without being able to go on and I had to borrow some money from Bjork's producer to get a ticket to get into New York.
Wow They were very kind.
That's my daughter singing in in the background.
Can you hear her?
She's singing kind of well there you should I'll I'll send you a tape of this and you'll have your music.
Okay.
That would be very nice.
Maybe I can do that, yeah.
A little baby screaming in the ice case.
And how old is she?
Um she's gonna be one in a couple of weeks.
Oh isn't that wonderful.
Yeah.
Good for you.
I think that she's a she's she really wants to be um out of the gallery space.
She wants some fresh air.
Yeah, I think so.
Well it's nice to hear her in the background because it makes it all more human.
It is it's so hard for me to picture like the other night when I was finishing up the uh winter issue of that uh hologram newsletter that I do.
Mm-hmm.
I was finishing it up in between loads of laundry.
Oh yeah.
And I came back down and I thought, you know, I can't picture anyone in holography doing laundry.
I can only picture them working in a lab or having exhibits.
But we're all human.
We all do laundry.
We all have families.
We all have all this that uh you know sometimes we never get to see the human side of the people that uh we follow their work of Yeah, I know.
I I was talking with my supervisor Paula Dawson about um this artist Doris Villa.
Yes.
And she was telling me how how Doris Villa was creating her work that she was like just you know, making five hour long kind of ex I mean not not five hour long exposures, but multi exposures over really long times that it kind of turned into a performance.
Oh.
You know, where she was like I don't know, it's a rumor like I have nothing to back up this this maybe it's just a fantasy I have about her working or something but where she would, you know, go up and make this exposure and then go down and cook dinner and then go up and do another exposure.
But yeah I think it has the same kind of the same rhythm, the same everyday performance thing.
Well Amy I want to wish you the best of luck.
Thank you so much.
And good luck with your tour which is New York New York Iceland Iceland London London and Germany.
Yeah.
And then what will you do after that?
Go back home?
I don't know, I'll have to see what happens my my boyfriend lives in I mean he he's from France so I think he's gonna try and convince me to stay in France That would be very nice.
Well it would be nice if you did speak French.
Oh I can't speak French.
Oh, neither can I.
I have a hard time speaking English.
Yes.
You know Oh, that's nice.
You did very well you have a very nice business voice.
Oh, thank you so much.
Okay.
Alright, well you take care, Amy.
You too.
And thank you for taking the time to come on to the show.
I'm sure everybody's going to enjoy listening to all the things you had to say so far.
Oh, thank you so much.
All right, thank you so much.
Bye.
Bye bye.